we know comes the leader of the
opposition Can't Stop
Mr Speaker
can I thank all those who took part in
the coronation celebrations over the
weekend and can I also take this chance
to wish all the very best to my
brilliant and talented constituent May
Muller who is representing the UK
Eurovision in Liverpool this weekend
country is behind you may
now Mr Speaker this time last week the
Prime Minister had to correct the record
of misleading claims he made about
employment numbers can he provide a
further update now he's cost a thousand
Tory councilors their jobs
[Applause]
Mr Mr Speaker let me pass on my best
wishes to may as well for this weekend
Eurovision and with regard to the local
elections Mr Speaker maybe I can just
offer The Honorable gentleman a tiny bit
of advice from one of his predecessors
from one of one of his predecessors
one of one of his predecessors Tony
Blair who I was reading the other day
what did Tony Blair he said he said the
right honorable gentleman can be as
cocky as he likes about the local
elections come a general election policy
counts
and we know Mr Speaker
the the problem for him is he doesn't
have any
the Prime Minister said he was going to
lose a thousand seats and then he
managed it
13 years a Tory promised they actually
haven't broken
and this is the primates who's only had
to fight for two things in his life last
year he lost a Tory beauty contest to
the member for Southwest Norfolk who
then lost to a lettuce
last week when he finally came into
contact with voters he lost everywhere
no matter who the electorate is the
prime minister keeps entering a
two-horse race and somehow finishing
third
given his track record who does he think
he's actually got a mandate from
[Applause]
person who's broken every single promise
I mean to go through the list Mr Speaker
nationalizations NHS Outsourcing
Universal Credit and now tuition fees he
was Mr Speaker he was for them all
before he was against them he's not he's
not just the softy he's the flaky too
well Mr Speaker I can understand why the
prime minister's trying to wish away his
terrible results
the nonsense just doesn't work
and down the country people
people focus on the cost of living but
he's got no answers none is he planning
to carry on as if nothing happened and
ignore the message he was sent last week
or is he going to do what a labor
government would do and announce an
immediate freeze in council tax bills
[Applause]
his labor council is rightly to focus on
the cost of living perhaps they could
start with reducing council tax to the
level in conservative run areas
we're getting on withholding People's
Energy bills freezing fuel duty to help
them with the cost of living what is
stopping him having a plan is that
it's that Chancellor Reese
speaker she realized she realized that
she actually is what she said she
actually has to shock horror say where
the money is going to come from
within with okay with a 90 billion pound
black hole in her plans she's got a lot
of work to do
there's only one party that broke the
economy and they're sitting right there
and
it seems to me it seems to me to quote
one of his more electorally successful
predecessors nothing has changed still
blaming other people still refusing to
take the necessary action still not
listening to the country and on council
tax it's quite simple a labor government
would give every Council the grant they
need to freeze those bills fully paid
for by ending the handouts he's giving
some oil and gas giants so I ask him
again now his plan has been utterly
rejected why won't he do the same
Mr Speaker just a quick a quick history
lesson while he was busy while he was
busy softening sentences 13 years ago
let me just remind him what we inherited
it was the largest deficit in the G7
from labor higher unemployment the
coffers were totally empty and it didn't
stop there Mr Speaker after that they
wanted a longer lockdown and now now
they won't even oppose the picketers and
the protesters Mr Speaker
even in opposition they're damaging the
economy
[Applause]
it's just not listening even after the
entire country Mr Speaker from the Peak
District to the god of England rejected
his government last week he still thinks
that protecting oil and gas profits is
more important than freezing bills now I
shoulder prime minister must finally
have met some
Woodland recently
many of them understand why he insists
on protecting his precious non-dom tax
status rather than scrapping it and
using the money to train thousands of
doctors and nurses
Mr Speaker he he said that this money
would fund the NHS Workforce but that
plan was actually looked at by one of
his own colleagues recently now now that
person said that it would discourage
doctors and nurses from coming here and
but there was a two billion two Billy
pound there was a two billion pound
shortfall in his sons who said that it
was Aleister darling
he might remember those days it's when
labor bankrupted the economy
[Applause]
I think that is the definition of
nonsense this is the price of having a
tired worn out government fronted by a
prime minister who boasts he's never had
a working-class friend he's smiling his
way through the cost of living crisis
gloating about success while waiting
lists grow he's pretending that crime
house building schools are all just
doing fine while handing the country 24
tax Rises all with his name on them
[Music]
tourists can possibly provide the
answers Britain needs when the whole
country has already told him they're the
problem not the solution
is right we all do say some silly things
when we're younger I was a teenager and
he'll he'll know what I'm talking about
because I think in his 40s he was still
talking about abolishing the monarchy Mr
Speaker
but it's uh
Minister you see but it's this it's the
it's the same old got from him every
week Mr Speaker all politics and no
action we're getting on with halving
people's energy bills freezing fuel Duty
cutting the shots of cold care and
boosting pay well he's well he's busy
plotting coalitions we're getting on and
delivering for the British people
hey